they're also artists and I think they
make a big mistake they grab at
everything I'm just known as the person
that like I don't respond to money so
you know a lot of things have been
thrown my way and they're like that no I
don't think you heard me like how much
it's for and I'm like I don't think you
heard me I'm exhausted like in other
words some rich guy is having a wedding
or something before we'll pay you this
amount of money and I was at the end of
tour and I told them I'm not saying yes
to anything else I can't physically I'd
had walking pneumonia steadily for like
six months I feel like like I just
couldn't get well you'd think Young
Kelly Clarkson would say you know what
that's insane and someone's gonna pay me
for an hour two million dollars yes but
like also like I think Young Kelly is
still the same Kelly like I just don't
everybody I look I like to pay my bills
but when you come from nothing you
realize you don't need that to survive
when you got done with American Idol and
you start to become this big singing
sensation you had to give them six
albums right I'm gonna tell you
something right now actually Simon
Fuller who is the head of all it was pop
Idol originally then it turned into
American Idol he was my manager and
label whenever I won Idol and I'm going
to tell you what this is unheard of
I was so unhappy because he he wasn't
really the one that was there it was
people working under him and it just was
not a good
right fit and and it was like just
um character clashing like it was just
not cool
um like literally I had someone
underneath him come to my house and put
magazines in front of me like this is
what you have to do in order to compete
with today and I'm like
here's the thing I have no problem with
people being who they are if you want to
be naked on the front of a cover I think
you I am actually a nudist I love being
that kid but I just don't do that in
work life and so it's like I have no
problem with people doing it but like
when someone sit something down I was
like this is what you're competing with
this is who you have to be and they just
kept drilling me you know about who I
had to be and I was like I'm just gonna
rock this and people can like be into it
or like not and I'm gonna you know still
be alive at the end of the day and it'll
be fine so
um it was the people underneath that I
didn't like and I called him I was doing
MTV's Iced Out in New York and um I
called him I was just crying and I was
like you gotta let me go like you're not
here and I am I am miserable and I've
been doing this for years now with you
and he literally in that moment said oh
my gosh Kelly I had no idea I'm so sorry
like of course I will let you out I will
not only let you out I will help you
find management if you need to like I
want to show you he let me out and I
that now ever happens you never hear
what a decent guy no he's Simon Fuller's
an incredible man you didn't get along
with uh Clive Davis he took over RCA and
you probably thought wow Greg Clive
Davis he's a genius this is going to be
so good out and he I was invited to his
house like Upstate New York he we had a
dinner I was so excited I literally it
was like a dream come true working with
this person that had worked with so many
people that I love the problem with he
and I is he literally was like you just
need to shut up and sing he wanted me to
be a Whitney Houston I love Whitney
Houston we know this but I don't want to
be her like I was like that's not like
he was against all the guitars like with
since you've been gone or Miss
Independent even that first single that
I came out with like it was just a
really hard relationship that was not a
good relationship with me now here's the
thing I don't prefer him and will never
barbecue with him but
do I think that he's had massive success
with other artists and is like obviously
done really well like obviously
um
yeah he didn't get you
foreign